all right let's move along to some
comments from bill belichick regarding
scouting of players as it relates to
projecting what someone does in the
passing game of college to what they
will do in the passing game at the pro
level and he pointed out something that
i have believed for a long time that it
is very difficult because of the caliber
of the opponent if you are going against
a defense that doesn't have highly
skilled defensive backs there's a much
bigger margin for error when you're
throwing the football there's less
concern about interceptions there's less
concern about guys not getting open
there's less concerns about getting
flattened by a great pass rusher but you
know chris how how much harder does it
make it when you're looking at film of
quarterbacks how hard is it to try to
remind yourself hey one of the reasons
this guy looks so good is because the
defense he's playing has a bunch of guys
who wouldn't make it in the cfl much
like the much less the nfl huge part of
the process that i think gets overlooked
not only by media members who are in the
draft but also professional you know nfl
evaluators at times and to further what
you're saying yes you have to evaluate
the talent level they're playing against
you have to evaluate also the talent
level that's
on their own team you know that's
something i look at you know even a
comparison like dwayne dwayne haskins
and drew locke you know dwayne haskins
had the luxury
of starting games slow and not taking
any chances and uh you know i might miss
a pass because i'm careful here because
why he was on ohio state and they were
the best team on the field like 99 out
of 100 times he had a defense where he
goes you know i can punt the ball two or
three times here to start the game and
it'll still be zero zero and then you go
to a drew lock where you go man his
team's not very good it's in the sec
okay gosh and they're the worst team on
the field unless they play maybe
vanderbilt uh every week in the sec to
where he's not afforded that luxury and
he's got to take more chances which can
lead to mistakes and things like that so
you have to take that into an account
and yes when i evaluate a big 12
quarterback right now right you know
will greer i think that's a perfect
example i mean we're not even talking
about anybody in the big 12 on the
defensive side of the ball going in the
first three rounds of the draft that's
how horrible defense is in the big 12.
not only the schemes horrible the
players are horrible and i think it
leads to people over evaluating a wheel
will grier in certain cases where i want
to go yeah okay here's some good things
and he's a nice little player but damn
every time he completes a pass the guy's
wide open there's never any nfl
similar type throws to evaluate and when
there are similar type throws it usually
doesn't work out into will grier's favor
so it's a big part of the process sorry
for the long winning answer there you
got big you got a big problem with the
big 12 defense is that what you're
saying i do yes the big 12 right now is
absolutely horrible it probably led me
to
uh maybe misevaluate even baker mayfield
a little bit last year because oklahoma
was the best team in the big 12. it
wasn't even close but yes it's a flag
football conference it's a far cry from
what it used to be when i was there uh
it is now truly flag football seven on
seven 70 points a game and i hate
watching it actually
what other quarterback came out of the
big 12 recently uh other quarterbacks
out of the big 12 recently are you
asking me that as in you're knowing um
am i missing something i'm just curious
i'm curious if there's any i don't know
uh reigning mvps that you may be missing
well yes patrick mahomes is there no
question about it yes and there hey
that's another great example you're
right that to me like those examples and
baker and patrick of holmes don't overdo
it with evaluating some of the maybe
defensive players in the big 12. just
evaluate the talent on the field and
what they're doing as a player in
general and leave it at that that's the
lesson i learned last year with baker
mayfield
but will that actually help greer
because i know the knee-jerk reaction
and i've fallen victim to this saying oh
yeah you know yeah as long as the guy is
wide open will reel be fine
will it help and you know what what kind
of and joel siegel represents will grier
and he's a great salesman and he starts
working on these play hey look it's the
same conference that generated patrick
my homes and baker mayfield i mean you i
could i can hear that pushback and will
that convince somebody who's desperate
for a quarterback to just roll the dice
and say you know what i got to give it a
shot here maybe this guy is going to be
great just like mayfield and mahomes
were yeah i think that there will be
people that fall to that trap yes and
they're gonna get fall in the trap of
the numbers and then yes always been
coached well by dana holgerson all of
those things yes but at the end of the
day this is what i would argue and these
are things i saw with baker mayfield and
patrick mahomes that i don't see with
will greer is what is it about the
player that's special you know i turned
on the film with mahomes and mayfield
and on the third throw i watched i went
these guys are special holy cow they can
really throw it this is unbelievable and
then you go into the athleticism grier's
arm is below nfl average standards for a
starting quarterback his athleticism is
below nfl average standards for a
quarterback and to me just there from
that base premises alone tells you or
tells me he's not a top 32 pick he's not
top 45 pick uh but he'll probably get
overdrafted because he is a quarterback
and had good numbers in college
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports